welcome back and let's bring in Ben
Shapiro editor-in-chief of The Daily
wire and host of the Ben Shapiro Show
podcast which I listen to every day Ben
I want to talk to you about this bill
that the President signed today but just
before the show started the
Congressional Budget Office put out this
number they are estimating a 12% drop in
GDP for this quarter forty percent
annualized and federal debt to exceed
GDP by the end of the year and I know
these are things you think about a lot
and maybe get your take on the president
signing this bill but what happens on
the other end of it I mean that is the
big question because the underlying
market fundamentals have changed I mean
the fact is that you can tell people
that they ought to stop being in
lockdown and it's still their consumer
behavior is going to change fairly
radically I think it's gonna be a while
before we have a therapeutic treatment
that lowers the risk of this thing if
you're above the age of 60 if you have
pre-existing conditions that describes a
large percentage of the population
you're just not gonna be eating in a
restaurant right next to somebody for a
long time you're not gonna be going to a
sporting event for a long time you're
probably not going to be in a retail
establishment that's highly crowded for
a very long time and that means that
actually it's more important not less
important to get people back to work so
that we can see how the markets play all
of this out so we can see which areas of
the economy are going to grow in sort of
the new demand world and people can move
from jobs that no longer exist to jobs
that will exist because the economy will
move in a different direction it's just
this is this is a sudden shock it's
gonna take a while for the economy to
recover it's not gonna be a v-shaped
recovery what do you think about the
tension between the the desire to reopen
and then sort the on the other side of
it some people including the media
looking out at them and saying it's too
soon don't be foolish and you're having
this real almost a cultural divide well
I think that a large part of what's
happening here is that Americans do
understand that or they should
understand that there is no situation
which everybody is absolutely safe
whether the threat comes to an end where
people go back to work and now they can
go without masks without social
distancing and the risk level is what it
was before any of this happened and I
think that that needs to be constantly
reinforced I also think that it's
important for politicians not to play
the the ridiculous game where they
suggest that if only we save a single
life then any policy is justified that's
the
last refuge of the political scoundrel
policymaking is always about weighing
competing values and weighing exactly
the cost to not only human liberty but
see human prosperity the number of lives
ruined not just the number of lives lost
what it looks like when you have 30
million people suddenly out of work
these are serious concerns and only
unserious people suggest that any policy
that is going to be taken is not going
to have costs and risks single factor
analysis here is the enemy of good sense
and that's why Andrew Cuomo is going to
end up opening up parts of New York
understanding that the risk still exists
for a lot of people that's just going to
happen the same thing will happen in
Illinois the same thing will happen in
California the question is how these
governor's assess that risk and exactly
what the current lockdown measures are
designed to do I think that very often
the media do a poor job explaining when
they said flatten the curve that was
designed to prevent the capacity of the
health care system from being exceeded
it was not designed to prevent everybody
from getting this in the first place
that just is not going to happen the the
testing regimens that people are talking
about those are designed to identify hot
spots to prevent spikes that again
prevent the healthcare system from being
overwhelmed they're not designed to
prevent huge numbers of people from
getting this over a long period of time
understanding that allows people to be
more sane in their risk assessment and
to be more rational about what exactly
society is going to look like coming out
of this because I think a too rosy and
optimistic picture of how safe we're
gonna be when this ends is a danger and
I think similarly a to pessimistic
version of what this looks like is also
going to be a danger there's also this
problem of that if you reopen and people
are so expected to go back to work but
the childcare centers and the schools
are still closed how our parents
supposed to make those decisions give
you the last word yeah I mean that
that's exactly right and again I think
that in the end we live in a republic
individual citizens are gonna have to
make decisions that don't threaten other
people but that allow them to live their
lives in a way that they feel
comfortable with and that risk
assessment is going to vary based on
person in a free country we're all going
to have to do that and to pretend
otherwise is simply just political line
ben shapiro thank you say hello to your
family and shabbat shalom
we'll see you hey thanks so much again
thank you